[Music]
it is so exciting
to see some of you um
i say that because i'm totally behind my
left eye and my ride come sleep from my
hand up so this is how i wandered earth
every day
you'll see me stumbling through team
cocoa tonight missing people's
handshakes and stepping on toes and
squeezing c and d cups on accident
it's just the cross i gotta carry
so i had these two surges that changed
my life the blonde i went really crooked
and i got self-conscious because no
matter how good looking you think you
are when one of your eyes are swirling
around that cookie monster
people looking at the eye
i mean halle berry is physically
flawless but one of her eyes just
started doing the dougie for no good
reason
she'd be wearing eye patch doing german
porn today
so
after i got this eye surgically repaired
and straightened out that's when i found
out how people really felt about my old
weird eye because their enthusiasm about
new eye was too insulting
like daryl you looking right at me
you look like a normal human being
i can't wait to have sexy with my eyes
open now baby
i thought her eyes was closed because i
was killing her you know what i mean
you know what i mean
i thought i was making her dizzy my
deliciousness that's what i thought i
was doing
i didn't know i was affecting her gag
reflex of my wobbly ass
this procedure was so serious i had one
doctor tell me we can try the surgery
and it might work but it probably won't
might work but probably won't
how many years of medical school is that
everything might work but probably won't
me trying to fix it myself might work
but probably won't
[Applause]
[Music]
who would do anything with those kind of
options
you could try to make a sudden move to
your pocket in front of police and it
might work but probably won't
you try to get a big black woman to
celebrate quietly on the prices right
and guess what
[Applause]
[Music]
i found a canadian surgeon that was
willing to do it he told me this is
risky and there's a chance you could end
up totally blind are you prepared for
that
hell no i'm not prepared for that
i want to choose to learn how to play
the harmonica i don't want to have to
learn how to play my monster
oh i was so scared i started having
nightmares about suicide and i really
believed that i'd do it if the surgeon
went wrong this i know god has a sense
of humor and the military to hear the
voice go would you really kill yourself
if you was totally blind
i said i think i would
i heard that same voice go how you be
totally blind
and i hadn't thought that far
then i started thinking how goofy i'd
look trying to kill myself lying at the
house
my wife come home there's a misspelt
note next to my head
i got a bottle of olive oil in my hand
i think about d and eminem just
scattered all across my face
she come in i got her hair dryer goodbye
cool
what are you doing i'm blowing my brains
out baby
she's like you're not gonna blow them
out you're gonna blow them dry but
they're still gonna be in there
and why is the breadbox in the bathtub
i thought it was a toaster
so it's a success my eyes always gonna
be just okay but i think i could do
different stuff down in my eyes okay you
know what my big goals is now i can't
wait to be
a eyewitness like i've been drinking
about this
[Applause]
thank you very much thank you very much
god bless you guys have a good night
hey
that's great
[Applause]